hey guys now of all the skincare
products out there in the world it's
really a hard to know which products
really work and which don't
so in this video I'm gonna show you the
three top skincare products for men that
actually work let's not waste any more
time let's get right to the video all
right guys first up is PC for men I've
used them for years and it's really
really hard to beat now Paula be gone I
hope that's how I pronounce her surname
but she's the founder and she's one of
the few people in the skincare industry
that brought truth into skincare she
wrote 20 best-selling books and appeared
on talk shows like Oprah and CNN now the
skincare routine is not that cheap
compared to normal drugstore skincare
products but you probably realize by now
that normal drugstore products skin care
products especially doesn't really work
that great for your skin
now PC for men has five products in
their skincare routine for all skin
types the face wash which is a soap free
formula the soothe and smooth which is
great because it is a 2% PHA exfoliant
that comes and reduces red bumps and
then the daytime protect which is a
daily moisturizer with SPF 13 and it
doesn't make your face shiny or oily and
then the nighttime repair this is the
nighttime moisturizer that helps your
skin to be smoother and more even toned
and lastly is the shaving cream and as
always I'll add all the links of the
products in a video description down
below so it's easier for you to go and
check them out and do your own research
next up is geology this is a new comer
that everybody is talking about and I
personally tried them out for around 4
months and they are right up there with
PC for men so the products are really
great just like their customer service
actually I think their customer service
is a little bit better than PC for men
I'm just saying that from personal
experience but yeah you can trust them
they are great I made a whole video
about them a while ago you can check
that out I'll also add that for
interview description if you're curious
the next stop and you've probably heard
about them before but it is TG Hanley
now teach Hanley I did a whole video
about them as well before I tried them
out and can you trust it yes does it
work yes if you're uncomplicated yes the
customer service is great you can get a
normal skin care system and also an acne
system for guys struggling with pimples
or acne the only thing I didn't like
about TJ honey was in their directions
when they said you should use a
pea-sized amount on your face and that's
not enough that's the only negative
thing that I experienced from them but
apart from that it works
no I did a full review of TJ Handley
where I go into detail so you can check
that out and if you want more options of
other skincare brands then I'll add that
for you Nvidia description as well now
just remember taking good care of
yourself of your skin is not about
self-importance or about being vain it's
about respecting yourself cheers guys